A few days ago,
Facebook proudly announced that they had achieved 8 billion video views a day.
That's really impressive until you done that in the first quarter of 2015 725 of
the thousand most viewed videos on Facebook was stolen,
amassing a total of 17 billion views,
sites and content aggregators,
steel videos from Youtube to go viral on Facebook.
These videos go viral because Facebook is cheating.
They read their algorithms so that video's uploaded into their player.
I'll prefer to youtube links because users should be kept as long as possible on
the site so Facebook can show them as many ads as possible.
This is after all their business model,
but it also cheats when it comes to views.
A view is counted after three seconds,
even if the video is muted,
which means that because of auto play,
if you scroll through your timeline slowly enough,
you count as a viewer.
That means engagement is terrible compared to youtube views.
Facebook views plummet after a few seconds because most of use are not real,
but large numbers are impressive.
Soap.
Facebook keeps pretending while this forced of identity is where the real
problem is.
The so called free booting,
the stealing of videos.
Since Facebook prefers its own player,
stolen videos reach way more people than the original.
Lately this has happened to us more and more often.
The most recent example of mass,
3.2 million views and 140,000 shares in two days.
While our own post just reached 100,000 people and got shared 1000 times,
other creators are headed even harder,
smarter every day.
His videos get sold in constantly getting viewed up to 17 million times,
but even this is dwarfed by examples like Tyrese Gibson,
a singer who steals viral videos like this one with 86 million views on his
Facebook page.
He adds a link to buy his music too.
He's not alone in this.
A whole group of people have built their online presence around stealing other
people's work.
This is really bad for independent creators.
Contrary to popular belief stolen content gives,
creates as close to no exposure at all.
Only the thief and Facebook profit from this quality content takes a lot of
creativity,
time and love.
In our case,
a single video literally takes hundreds of hours to make even weight with more
than a million subscribers aren't dependent on the ads and exposure without ads
and the support of our generous patrons.
We could not make videos for a small creator of viral video can mean the
difference between a career and a hobby.
On Youtube.
There's kind of,
theft is not a problem because they have major safeguards that protect content
from being stolen.
Although the content ID system is far from perfect,
especially for film critics and Gamers.
Facebook,
on the other hand,
pretends everything is fine and constantly announces one milestone after the
other,
but things are not fine.
Let's look at the process of claiming your copyright on Facebook in the last
year.
One,
get an email or a tweet from a fan that gives you a direct link to your video.
It's not possible to search for your videos on Facebook yourself.
You depend on luck to find your stolen videos,
to search for Facebook copyright infringement on Google because it's actually
faster this way.
Three,
fill out an annoyingly long contact form for what's the views on your stolen
videos rise.
Five Facebook finally pulls the video.
Conveniently.
The video has already gained in 99% of all the views that we'll ever get.
The thief doesn't have to fear any negative consequences at all.
This is what successful creators have to deal with constantly and on top of
losing out in terms of exposure and money.
It just feels like a violation to be treated like that.
In a recent statement.
Facebook announced they want to change,
but it's hard to take them seriously when it still takes days for a stolen viral
video to be taken down and Facebook does not share the profits made from it.
At this point,
Facebook is not a partner.
Creators look forward to working with.
They've built their video empire on stolen content and disregard for original
content creators.
This is absolutely unacceptable for a corporation worth billions of dollars.
Facebook is already testing various monetization models that will give the
uploaders eight cart of the ad revenue,
which with the current state of play is troubling right now.
This is mainly being tested with big media companies,
but as creators,
we don't feel like we're being asked all taken into consideration by the giant
that is Facebook.
What can you as a viewer do to help here?
If you spot stolen content on Facebook,
make a comment linking to the original content.
Alert the original creator because only they can file a copyright report,
share this video or the one done by smarter every day.
We all want the same thing,
a free internet that the basis for creativity,
community and great stuff.
We sincerely hope that Facebook will soon become a partner instead.
An obstacle to this goal for more in depth information.
We recommend this article by Hank Green and if you want to support us in our
endeavor to survive in the world of online video and make more videos,
you can do so on patrion.com.